[Music]
and ultimate wedding scam news there's a
drag queen on RuPaul that's okay anyway
so submitted by sticky hey do you know
them Steven icky Steven thank you stick
it they'd like you to know my branding I
would like you to use I thought we meant
something you do it again and no my
branding um okay I'm gonna toast again
submitted by CQG better way better
is it sticky key it's close it's really
good your goals is [ __ ] I'm sorry hey
yeah yeah a bride canceled her wedding
after ranky raking and 3,000 new
donations to just go in a lavish
honeymoon instead I think that's
actually pretty good
yes no I didn't catch anything she
didn't catch it I ever felt you Barta a
bride canceled her wedding after rape
raking in thirty thousand dollars of
donations just to go in a lavish
honeymoon instead where what's donations
like wedding gifts like people were like
honey funding underwear what is that
this post was it originally surfaced on
reddit under the subreddit choosing
beggars and then that's when there was
this post I will show it to you this is
what it looks like I will read it it
says this is from the bride hi invitees
to the Pam and Edward I believe it's
what they redacted it wedding after much
reflection and tear-filled conversation
with our closest family members we have
decided to cancel our upcoming winter
wedding we will further notify this
group when we are in a better place to
reschedule we thank you wait sorry we
thank each and every one of you for your
generous early donations to our Lenny
fund can you believe we have raised over
$30,000 unbelievable don't worry the
money you've donated will not be spent
in vain but rather use toward a
honeymoon in the coming months after we
regain re regain financial stability and
hold calm in our hearts after a
honeymoon we will announce a new wedding
date and reopen our money fund for any
future gifts
Wow weddings are expensive we are
blessed to have generous family members
who gave us these large donations it
will help offset honeymoon costs and to
scale to an even better future wedding
we really couldn't have made it this far
without you please stay tuned in the
meantime I'll be a little far can't do
that wedding cancellation a thirty
thousand dollar honeymoon brother why
don't you put that on a down payment but
I was thinking too like that's so until
our funds get why are you wasting it on
a honeymoon but not just that they're
asking for more that's the legendary
I'll open it back up yeah in the
meantime I'll be updating our gift fund
registry on Amazon if anyone will like
to gift us something to take on a
honeymoon if you have any ideas on where
we can go please p.m. me or something as
mentioned we will keep you updated when
we are reopening our money fund and have
a new wedding date in the works don't be
too sad the new wedding is gonna be a
hit well let you know when we're able to
process more payments thank you oh my
god there were more screenshots to this
story this is one of them and it says at
the top it says family member of the
groom says is this a [ __ ] joke after
rape wrecking in raking a wrecking
raking in $30,000 you decide to be
greedy and use it all for yourselves the
bride's friend says Pam what did I tell
you about Dave drinking in all
seriousness is the wedding really
canceled I've already gotten the time
off for December 1st which is less than
a month away the another one of bride's
friends said all right step the [ __ ]
back what and then the bride said oh
please calm down please calm down you're
making me feel very attacked and hang up
on you chose to donate to me if I want
to use the money who cares how I told
you the wedding is getting rescheduled
not canceled but you need to donate more
in order to well why would you feel why
would you feel bad for vacations are
really fun why isn't there why isn't it
okay to ask for money when you're going
through a divorce
instead of like for a wedding you know
what I mean that's because we all gets a
party at your wedding
divorce have a divorce party I will
donate to your divorce I had so many
people say that they were gonna make me
one and it never happened okay I'm
alright I wish it were actually but it's
fine you don't remember but you totally
said I'm sure you don't remember I'm
sure you don't oh yeah pretty much every
conversation of how they do has been
totally meaningless to me
it's flushable they're flexible
conversations it's unmemorable yeah
Nikki you're a great actor because I
would have never guessed that one second
one second thank you all right so the
bride's aunt comments on that thought I
would like my $3,500 donation returned
and will not be attending the new
wedding event please return my money and
fold to blank you can do a cashiers
check or money order certified funds
only please the rich uncle says you
aren't responding to my calls or texts
so I'm just gonna tell you you are to
return my more than generous $12,000
donation on behalf of the blank family
in one week if on 1113 2018 I do not see
my money in cash in my bank account I
will be seeing you in court
this is unacceptable and is betrayal
toward your family members so that she
ends up writing a very long thing that
I'm not gonna read but pretty much she's
saying at the end of it once I recover I
will decide when we can all talk in
person to discuss this situation I hope
to have a wedding but I'm not sure if
this trust may be rebuilt in the
meantime please consider donating any
spa or personal care items to my home
address if you even care about me at all
we've lost close to $3,000 from the
money funds due to medical expenses and
we would like to so we only have $27,000
hold on we would like the more affluent
members of the family to consider
donations as a courtesy
she model or something like yeah like
her who is this she's insane so this
story went viral a lot of media outlets
picked it up and they were just like the
headlines our bride steals 30 K of
wedding donations and then ask for more
right cancels wedding and keeps the 30 K
they received in donation
all these headlines right the original
poster on reddit promised to share an
update with more comments from Pam's
family and friends but it ended up being
uploaded these new images were being
uploaded to this website called captured
it dot Club and so this is the home page
captured it dot Club Club yeah captured
it club it says your social media drama
captured and so these new images were
uploaded to that website which me which
seems to be a site that delivers social
media drama right so people start
looking into this domain and then they
realize that this website was brand new
it was created the same day the reddit
post was made damn and then so they
they're only they're only drama stories
that they had was just this one which is
this one the bride steals 30k of winning
donations full update and so they added
more screenshots and someone noticed
that in the screenshot of the the reddit
chat the way that it was viewed you
could only see it if you're the one
logged into the reddit account of like
the original one so pretty much people
were like this shit's [ __ ] fake like
this was all fabricated somehow because
like the it was based off that one
screenshot it really and then also the
fact that the domain was was the same
date as the reddit post push the website
thank ya so then eventually the website
changed and looks and looked like this
but then that's when BuzzFeed ended up
posting all of this like evidence that
they've accumulated against this story
and then after a BuzzFeed article that's
when the website was updated with this
it says been hubs pranksters submitted
oh my goodness I mean it's not that good
of praying yeah I'm confused cause a
bull story that would actually happen do
you think that she's getting now that
she's getting all this attention now
there's some person out there that might
want to donate so the person might be
fake that it's fake
the story is fake how dare you leave me
on this entire time you let me down this
journey I was on I was here with you it
was like honest I was vulnerable and now
I just go in I became I'm honest and I
told you there are people like that
though we just went on like a full three
month date and then you just decided you
were done with me
true I'm sorry how do you cope with this
deal I don't know man Gio already advice
I like that just move on girl
I like that five minutes like that five
minutes of misleading you feels like
three months you you are truly a scary
person today I was like God [ __ ] in
trouble that is frightening no we were
on a date we were practically married
now she's in a group chat with all our
personalities I swear to you guys I am
mentally stable okay
I just don't like the guys that I pick
you've been sipping an empty cup for
like there's like this for me it's so
sweet now it's over it's been sounded
like that for a while yeah if she picked
up again we'll know it's her insecure
move I have melted at the end of it okay
I don't yeah we would like to hear a
jingle around tonight just drink it all
mother no we would like to hear a jingle
around in the cup I just drank you know
you said that you have Isis I had that's
where it all melted that's why it's like
that's why I kept hearing emptiness yeah
so this story I'm not gonna go there
you're drinking your soul no yours
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]